>> Jesse: LIBERAL MEDIA
MELTING DOWN AFTER INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS TESTIFIED ON ISIS,
NORTH KOREA, AND IRAN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
INTELLIGENCE CHIEFS ARE WORLDS
APART ON ISIS, RUSSIA, AND THE
BORDER.
>> THIS WAS A PUBLIC REPUDIATION
BY HIS OWN PEOPLE OF
DONALD TRUMP'S WORLDVIEW.
>> WE ARE DESCRIBING A DIFFERENT
PLANET THAN THE ONE DONALD TRUMP
AND HABITS.
>> DISPARITY BETWEEN WHAT THEY
PRESENTED AND THE PLANET THE
PRESIDENT LIVES ON.
SPEAK A WORD IS THE PRESIDENT
GET INTELLIGENCE AND FOREIGN
POLICY ADVICE ON?
>> NOT AGREEING WITH THESE
CONCLUSIONS IS WILLFUL
DISREGARD.
>> IT'S A DANGEROUS THING.
>> Jesse: AFTER THE MEDIA
FREAK OUT, THE PRESIDENT CALLING
THE INTEL CHIEFS PASSIVE AND
NAIVE WHEN IT COMES TO IRAN.
THE PRESIDENT HAS MADE THE MEDIA
TAKE THE SIDE OF THE INTEL
AGENCIES.
THEY'VE NEVER DONE THAT BEFORE.
>> Jesse: AREN'T THEY
FORGETTING 2003?
>> Jesse: VERY CRITICAL BACK
THEN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK IS GOING ON
WITH THE PRESIDENT AND HIS MEN
AT THE TOP.
>> Dana: WE COVER IT.
IT'S THE STORY ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT AND THE MEDIA.
I AM ACTUALLY MELTING DOWN ABOUT
THE THREATS.
IT IS SUPER SERIOUS.
WE ARE BEHIND ON THE CYBER WAR,
ESPECIALLY CHINA AND RUSSIA.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THIS HEARING
EVERY YEAR BECAUSE I WANT TO
KNOW, WHAT ARE THE PROBLEMS.
>> Jesse: DANA PERINO,
EVERYBODY.
YOU LOOK FORWARD TO IT.
I DO TOO BUT I DON'T REMEMBER OF
IT UNTIL THE DAY BEFORE.
>> Dana: HE ALSO SAID IN HIS
TWEET THAT THEY SHOULD GO BACK
TO SCHOOL.
THEY WORK VERY HARD FOR HIM
EVERY DAY.
THROWING SHADE.
>> Jesse: DID YOU SAY THROWING
SHADE?
>> Dana: IS THAT WOKE?
>> Jesse: GREG, WHAT DO YOU
THINK IS HAPPENING HERE?
CRITICAL OF THE INTEL PEOPLE.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA IS
DEMANDING EVERYBODY AGREES.
THEY CAN'T BE HAPPY.
THEY CALL IT DISPARITY BUT IT'S
NOT LOCKSTEP.
THEY WANT LOCKSTEP THEM IF THEY
DON'T SEE IT, IT'S CALLED
DISPARITY.
THEY KEEP PARSING HIS TWEETS.
THEY ARE LIKE OLD GUYS ON THE
BEACH WITH METAL DETECTORS
HOPING TO FIND A BOTTLE CAP.
THEY OVERLOOK BIGGER STORIES.
PERHAPS THIS IS WORKING.
THE FACT THAT THE GOOD COP BAD
COP THING THAT WAS GOING ON WITH
SYRIA I THINK MIGHT BE WORKING.
NORTH KOREA HAD A GOOD COP BAD
COP THING WHERE PEOPLE WERE
DISAGREEING.
THAT SEEMS TO BE WORKING.
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S
PROGRESS THERE.
IT'S BETTER THAN IT WAS LAST
YEAR AND YOU HAVE TO ADMIT IT
AND YOU CAN HOLD TWO IDEAS IN
YOUR HEAD.
WE ARE DESTROYING ISIS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO DESTROY
ISIS.
IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE THE PRISON
OF TWO IDEAS.
YOU SAID WE DESTROYED ISIS BUT
THEY ARE STILL HERE.
YOU CAN HAVE BOTH.
WE ARE DESTROYING AND CONTINUING
TO DESTROY.
THE MEDIA WANTS YOU TO BE IN
THEIR PRISON OF TWO IDEAS.
LET THEM STAY THERE.
YOU HAVE A FREE MIND.
YOU ARE SMARTER THAN THEY ARE
AND YOU MAKE MORE MONEY THAN
THEY ARE.
JESSE.
>> Katie: MUCH SMARTER.
>> Jesse: TAKE IT AWAY.
>> Katie: THERE'S PLENTY OF
ROOM FOR SKEPTICISM WHEN IT
COMES TO WHAT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS SAYING AND THE
SOURCING THESE MEDIA OUTLETS ARE
USING TO PUSH A CERTAIN AGENDA
WHEN IT COMES TO FOREIGN POLICY.
HOWEVER, WHEN IT COMES TO THE
THREATS WE DO FACE, I WAS AT A
CYBERSECURITY PANEL LAST WEEK AT
FOUNDATION FOR DEFENSE OF
DEMOCRACIES AND THEY WERE SAYING
WITH CYBER, THE GOOD NEWS IS
BOTH ADVERSARIES, UNITED STATES,
RUSSIA, CHINA, WHERE BAD AT
RESPONDING ARE BETTER AT
ATTACKING.
THAT'S HER ANALYSIS.
WE HAVE TO GET BETTER AT CYBER.
IT'S A SERIOUS THING.
THERE WAS TALK OF WAYS TO
RESPOND.
WHILE WE ARE ALL FIGHTING OVER
WHO SAID WHAT AND WHO AGREES
WITH WHAT, THERE ARE REAL THINGS
HAPPENING BEHIND THE SCENES THAT
WE NEED GOOD PEOPLE TO BE DOING.
WHEN IT COMES TO THE ISIS THING,
YEAH, WE'VE SEEN A NUMBER OF
ISIS ATTACKS AFTER THE PRESIDENT
HAS SAID DIRECTLY THEY HAVE BEEN
DEFEATED.
IS HE TALKING ABOUT THE
TERRITORY?
YES.
DOES IT MEAN ISIS IS DEFEATED
ALL AROUND THE WORLD?
NO.
I GOT A PRESS RELEASE TODAY.
SOMEONE GOT ARRESTED IN THE
UNITED STATES AGAIN FOR GIVING
MATERIAL SUPPORT TO ISIS.
THAT COMES DOWN TO THE IDEOLOGY
OF ISLAMIC RADICALISM AND WHAT
OUR APPROACHES TO THAT.
>> Jesse: MAY BE THE
CONGRESSWOMAN FROM MINNESOTA CAN
WRITE A LETTER OF SUPPORT.
TO DANA'S POINT ABOUT THE
THREATS, THERE ARE SERIOUS
THREATS BUT THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN PRETTY STRONG ON ISIS,
NORTH KOREA, CHINA.
>> Greg: ON RUSSIA.
>> Jesse: HE'S BEEN EFFECTIVE
IN THOSE AREAS.
>> Juan: I AM LISTENING TO
THIS DEFENSE COMING FROM AT
LEAST THREE OF YOU AND I THINK
IT'S TISSUE THIN.
I GUESS YOU ARE DESPERATE.
>> Greg: EXPLAIN HOW IT'S
TISSUE THIN.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE TRUMP'S
PEOPLE SAYING WE'RE DOING DOING
A REALISTIC ASSESSMENT AND WE
ALL AGREE IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
DISAGREE.
NO, IT'S FBI, CIA DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE PUTTING
THEMSELVES ON THE LINE BEFORE
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
SAYING HERE'S THE REALITY.
IT'S NOT WHAT THIS GUY IS
SAYING, NOT WHAT TRUMP IS
SAYING.
THEY DON'T MENTION THE SOUTHERN
BORDER IS AN IMMEDIATE THREAT.
NO, THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT CHINA
AND RUSSIA WORKING TOGETHER
AGAINST US.
>> Greg: CHINA BEFORE --
>> Juan: THINK ABOUT
NORTH KOREA.
HE'S GOING TO GO MEET AGAIN.
FOR WHAT?
HE SAYS THINGS ARE BETTER THAN
EVER.
NO.
THEY ARE STILL INTENT ON
CREATING NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
HOW ABOUT IRAN?
TRUMP IS LIKE OH, YEAH, IRAN IS
TERRIBLE.
THEY ARE NOT VIOLATING THE TERMS
OF THE OBAMA AGREEMENT.
YOU NEVER HEAR THIS FROM TRUMP.
IT'S LIKE IT'S ON A DIFFERENT
PLANET AND YOU GUYS ARE -- I
DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT?
>> Greg: VENEZUELA IS
RESPONDING SAVING OR WILLING TO
COOPERATE.
MUST HAVE BEEN'S NOTEPAD.
>> Jesse: REMEMBER WHEN OBAMA
HAD THE INTEL PEOPLE COOK THE
BOOKS ON ISIS AND SAY NOT THAT
BIG OF A THREAT ANYMORE.
THE RISE OF ISIS, HE BLAMED THE
INTEL AGENCIES FOR MISSING IT.
REMEMBER WHEN HE WEAPONIZE THE
INTEL AGENCIES THAT GO AFTER
DONALD TRUMP.
>> Juan: LET'S DO A CURRENT
AFFAIRS SHOW ON
FOX NEWS CHANNEL.
WE LEARN TODAY THAT TRUMP WAS
TALKING WITH PUTIN PRIVATELY.